en allemagne mein kampf écrit par adolf
hitler en 1924 vient d'être réédité pour
la première fois depuis la fin de la
guerre l'allemagne qui réédite mein
kampf c'était en 2016
la couverture est sobre le titre
extrêmement clair c'est bien une version
critique de mein kampf trois ans de
travail par des historiens allemands
pour décortiquer le texte écrit par
hitler il ya 90 ans cette année là les
droits du livre d'adolphe hitler tombe
dans le domaine public
il a fait sa réapparition dans les
rayons des libraires l'année dernière et
depuis les ventes s'envolent 85 mille
exemplaires ont déjà été écoulés un
succès d'édition en allemagne mais
partout dans le monde des versions sont
publiés et à chaque fois c'est le même
succès comme ici en inde même ce petit
marchand de rue en proposent
il assure en vendre pour les jours le
livre a été traduit dans plusieurs
langues régionales
il s'en vend des dizaines de milliers
chaque année en france
il a donc fallu attendre 2021 pour avoir
une édition critique comprendre une
édition commentée par des historiens
mais avant ça mein kampf on pouvait
l'acheter sous le manteau preuve en est
avec cette caméra cachée en 1991
je cherche mein kampf the mind of vous
l'avez pas dans une plus belle édition
est pas facile on peut en trouver à des
prix encore raisonnable environ 5,6 en
france d'édition qu'on offrait aux
jeunes mariés
vous avez bien entendu mein kampf comme
cadeau de mariage remises aux jeunes
mariés dans les années 40 comme aux
beaux parents de ce strasbourgeois
d'emine cameron alsace je suis sûr que
les gens ne l'ont pas détruit ils l'ont
gardé comme ça dans un rayonnage
et lorsque quelqu'un décède les
héritiers disent tiens il l'avait il
n'en a jamais parlé
je ne dis pas que nous en étions fiers
sûrement pas aidé mein kampf dans les
maisons familiales
il y en a eu plus d'un en france et
outre rhin
à l'époque un foyer allemand sur deux
possède l ouvrage un succès non sans
conséquence pour l'historien denis
peschanski
on a là avec mind of un document
essentiel parce que il a structuré
l'imaginaire collectif des allemands
pendant tout le nazisme
ça a été un une arme de guerre une arme
de guerre qui donc quelques jours pourra
être à nouveau acheter en france avec
toutes les précautions qu'elle impose
[Musique]